they're not searching for survivors
anymore it's a search for the dead
three bodies are somewhere underneath
this concrete
we're told the two-year-old boy was
killed in this russian airstrike
there's at least three bodies still
under the rubble including kids shelling
makes our work very complicated even the
centre of town was hit it's very
difficult to work in such conditions
under the sound of constant artillery
fire they continue to work
the shock waves from the nearby
artillery and rockets shake the already
fragile building
when it happened the man covered the boy
with his body the child was in very bad
condition the head was injured the older
guy died other people who were sitting
on a bench had time to get into the
basement so they survived
we've just buried my friend he was 43
years old we've just come from the
cemetery and tomorrow we're burying
members of my family
this town of 70 000 has seen most of the
population leave
in the east the russian military have
been gaining ground
nowhere in bahamut is safe and many
people have become desensitized to the
constant sound of artillery and shell
fire but unlike other large cities the
emergency services here are really
struggling to deal with the destruction
and casualties as a result of this war
another strike on a residential building
in the early hours of the morning a
missile hit directly in front of here
ripping through the apartments the mayor
has told residents to evacuate
now they're in a rush to leave
scary and terrible this woman says
those that remain have a choice
evacuate from the town or hope to
survive the russian military onslaught
assad
al-jazeera bahamut